معنا الان من المستشفى المعمداني في مدينه
غزه مراسلنا اسماعيل الغول اسماعيل ما كنا
نتابعه بخصوص ما يجري بالقرب من مستشفى
الشفاء كيف هي تطوراته هل مازالت تلك
الاشتباكات
مستمره نعم حتى هذه اللحظات يتواصل القصف
المدفعي على تلك المنطقه بالاضافه الى
سماع دوي الرصاصات والطلقات الناريه
المتكرر في ظل وجود اشتباكات عنيفه ما بين
المقاومه الفل فلسطينيه وعلى راسها كتاب
القسام وباقي الفصائل التي تشارك في هذه
الاشتباكات علما ان هذه المنطقه تعرضت
لدخول بري عده مرات من قوات الاحتلال لكن
دائما ما تعيد المقاومه الفلسطينيه ترميم
نفسها بشكل سريع جدا والتواجد في المناطق
التي تنسحب منها قوات الاحتلال وايجاد
خطوط امداد جديده لتعزيز المقاومين في اي
منطقه يدخلها الاحتلال يبدو ان المقاومه
الفلسطينيه حتى هذه اللحظه نجحت من جديد
في اعاده تعزيز نفسها وا اعاده تمركزها
واعاده نشر قواتها في في منطقه الاتصالات
والمناطق المحيطه التي تتواجد بها قوات
الاحتلال منذ صباح هذا اليوم تسمع دوي
الاشتباكات بشكل عنيف جدا في تلك المنطقه
يبدو ان قوات الاحتلال لازالت تقع في
كمائن للمقاومه في تلك المنطقه ننتظر ما
يصدر عن الفصائل الفلسطينيه خلال الساعات
القادمه لكن على الناحيه الاخرى لازالت
طواقم الهلال الاحمر تبحث عن المفقودين
العناصر المفقوده من طواقمها هم يوسف زينو
واحمد المدهون الذين فقدوا اثر محاوله
اجلاء المصابه هند رجب او هند حماده هي
نفس العائله لكن
بتسميتي التي قصفت صباح امس وبقيت هي
ناجيه ناجيه وحيده في منطقه طرنبه فارس
قرب منطقه تل الهواء حتى هذه اللحظه لم
تصل ولم ترد اي اخبار من تلك المنطقه
بخصوص الطفله هند التي لم تبلغ من العمر
سوى سته سنوات بالاضافه الى الطواقم
الهلال الاحمر التي ذهبت بتنسيق مع قوات
الاحتلال الى تلك المنطقه لكن فقدت
التواصل مع طواقم الهلال الاحمر منذ مساء
امس حتى هذه اللحظه و ولا يوجد اي مجيب
سواء من الطفله هند التي كان كان التواصل
معها هي والطفله ليان بالاضافه الى طواقم
الهلال الاحمر انقطع الاتصال بشكل كامل
وبقوا بين زخات الرصاص
وازيز الطائرات الاحتلال التي تحلق في تلك
المنطقه بكثافه ا لا معلومات اذا عن هند
وعن طاقم الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني فقط
اشير الى هذا الخبر العاجل اسماعيل وانت
تتابع معنا هذه التطورات ينقل مراسلنا
الان اذا بان اصوات اشتباكات بالاسلحه
الثقيله تسمع في الضواحي الشرقيه لمدينه
غزه مدينه غزه اذا وهذا الاستهداف المكثف
الان منذ ايام ما هي تلك المواقع التي
تستهدف في مدينه غزه
اسماعيل نعم لكن للتصحيح او عفوا للتعديل
الاشتباكات تسمع في الم المناطق الغربيه
الجنوبيه لمدينه غزه وليس المناطق الشرقيه
بالتحديد هذه المنطقه المتاخمه لمنطقه
مستشفى الشفاء التي تقع بال ملاصقه مستشفى
الشفاء بشكل عنيف جدا تتواجد بها قوات
الاحتلال لكن الاستهدافات الاسرائيليه
ركزت صباح هذا اليوم في المناطق الشرقيه
الجنوبيه والشماليه ايضا من المناطق من
مناطق مدينه غزه حيث قصفت قوات الاحتلال
خمسه منازل على رؤوس ساكنيها بالاضافه الى
عدد كثير كبير من الشقق بالاضافه الى
تواصل القصف المدفعي على المناطق المختلفه
ان الشرقيه او حتى الغربيه هذا ياتي عقب
الاشتباكات التي تنجم في تلك المنطقه وهذا
ناجم او ما يفسر دائما ان قوات الاحتلال
قد تكون وقعت بكمين واو اشتباكات ضاريه مع
المقاومه الفلسطينيه التي تتواجد في كل
المناطق لازالت لليوم الس 16 عش على
التوالي ال16 على التوالي تتواجد في مختلف
محاور قطاع غزه تتصدى لاي توغل بري لقوات
الاحتلال شكرا جزيلا لك حتى الان اسماعيل
الغول كنت معنا من امام مستشفى المعمداني
في مدينه غزه